pendant ce temps à Bagdad le Premier
ministre Raymond Barre et le
vice-président irakien Saddam Hussein
souligné leur convergence politique
notamment sur l'analyse de la situation
au Proche et au Moyen-Orient principal
résultat de cette visite et de ses
conséquences Raymond Barre a pu se dire
confiance se déclarer confiance que
l'Irak approvisionnera la France en
pétrole dans les années à venir dans les
conditions de sécurité et de stabilité
avant la publication du communiqué final
Raymond Barre a fait ce matin une visite
au souk de Bagdad en s'attardant surtout
au marché des artisans du cuivre ce fut
l'un des rares moments de détente de ce
voyage qui a duré 48 heures et qui s'est
achevé ce soir bilan de cette visite par
Raymond Barre lui-même
j'ai rendu hommage à Monsieur Saddam
husseigne et au gouvernement irakien
pour la modération dont il a fait preuve
dont ils ont fait preuve et aussi pour
les témoignages d'amitié que qu'ils ont
donné à la France puisque au mois de
février dernier et Monsieur Saddam
Hussein avait répondu favorablement à la
demande que je lui avais adressé et pour
obtenir 5 millions de tonnes de pétrole
supplémentaires j'espère d'ailleurs que
dans le cadre de nos relations notre
approvisionnement pétrolier pourra
s'effectuer auprès de Dirac dans des
conditions de sécurité et de stabilité
au cours des années à venir
enfin nous avons parlé de relation
bilatérales le problème pétrolier est un
aspect de ces relations bilatérales tout
autant qu'un problème international
nous avons constaté que la grande
convergence de nos vues politiques
devait s'accompagner d'un
approfondissement de notre coopération
et d'une intensification de nos échanges
nous avons engagé déjà un certain nombre
d'actions avec le gouvernement irakien
dans le domaine de la coopération
nucléaire dans le domaine des
des télécommunications dans le domaine
des équipements tout récemment des
entreprises françaises se sont vues
confiées et la construction de
l'aéroport de Bagdad et j'espère qu'au
cours des prochains mois de nouveaux
contrats viendront confirmer
cette coopération étroite entre nos deux
pays